from Yahoo Ronnie James LeBron James's
18 year old son suffered Cardiac Arrest
here's what you need you need to know uh
I mean that's basically the story he was
on the he was he was practicing he had a
car he had a cardiac uh he had Cardiac
Arrest he was rushed to the hospital it
was very serious he's in stable
condition he survived the big news
however 18. oh my God the big news
outside of that is that uh Elon Brown
here here's the Daily Mail bronnie James
Cardiac Arrest is linked to the covid-19
vaccine Elon Musk suggests saying we
cannot ascribe everything to the vaccine
but by the same token we cannot ascribe
nothing musk wrote myocarditis is a
known side effect the only question is
whether it is rare or common musk's
tweet continued I will just say this as
I always start videos like this talk to
your doctor about what's right for you
find trusted mellow professionals a lot
of people don't trust the medical system
but there are people out there who are
good medical professionals you can trust
just do the work and uh the CDC says it
it is rare myocarditis but I wonder what
you guys think about this whole thing
can I say one thing one it seems to me
I'm going to put my tin foil hat on with
this issue it seems to me that one of
the big stresses where there the demand
was to get everyone as vaccinated as
possible was to socialize risk because
if everyone's invested and if bad things
start to happen where we're all in this
together whereas if you have one
population and that population has
consequences then it's like okay it's
happening to them it's now there's going
to be held to pay now it's like okay
wait wait you guys screwed up you know
people in Florida you guys screwed up
maybe young people whatever if it's
everybody then it's kind of like you
can't it's like that's how Corporate
corporate systems work bureaucracies
work if you distribute um the
consequences then really no one's to
blame but but here's but that also
created the perception of risk itself so
I'll say a few things the CDC says that
myocarditis is a rare side effect from
uh the MRNA vaccine specifically this is
the CDC saying it don't take my word for
it and myocarditis is listed as a cause
sometimes a cause of cardiac arrest in
young athletic males
that would easily mean that sometimes
people get the coveted vaccine may
suffer myocarditis and that may result
in Cardiac Arrest I believe it's
extremely rare however we gave out as of
October that was the latest number I
could find 630 at 37 or some some
ridiculous number of vaccine doses you
give out that many let's say it's one in
a million people who will get
myocarditis you're gonna have 600 and
some odd cases of myocarditis then
you're going to hear a bunch of stories
in the news and people are going to
assume many stories means it's happening
all the time when actually the same
percentage of people are suffering a
rare side effects yeah but you know
if you really were going to have some
trust and statistics you would have
hoped they would have used a control
group in the quote-unquote science which
they didn't so we don't really know how
many people we and plus I don't trust
their numbers anyway well but I think
that what happened to him is that global
warming got him oh yes but that's
another point or white supremacy no hold
on both very big issues but where where
are they at it was 120 degrees in Las
Vegas so uh he used to so hot right his
heart was going crazy pumping the heat
actually in all seriousness this in all
seriousness though when you're really
hot your heart pumps your blood like
crazy to move the heat through your body
so but it was hot and then he saw some
dudes from Saudi Arabia in the in the
traditional garb thought it was KKK
members had a heart attack we're all
joking but if you've ever been in that
Las Vegas heat I mean I about had
myocarditis when I was there like about
five years ago just walking outside to
the cab yeah but you were a senior
citizen you know what I mean he's like
an 18 year old athlete so but the other
thing is this why they're being
disingenuous is they're saying it's rare
death from covet is rare it was like one
person even if it's one if something
happens to one percent of the people
that's rare one percent murder I think
America is 330 million people and
there's like 20 000 murders so that's
statistically irrelevant it's rare but
are we going to pretend murder doesn't
matter so that word is kind of a weasel
word uh it could mean what you're saying
or it could mean that it's doubling what
it should have been but that's still
rare and we should when it comes to the
CDC though one thing that I find
interesting and you know I wear a
permanent tinfoil hat you know that baby
because I'm 70 I don't believe anything
anybody tells me but uh you know the
permanent thing they say is to really
check out what these Undertakers are
saying how the death rate went up in
what population for The Undertakers know
it and uh they say it's through the roof
of people you know and insurance
companies say it too their stuff went up
a hundred and you know million points
but I don't believe no it's people dying
uh from myocard
here's the thing I don't believe that
five years ago that there were enough
news articles of young athletes getting
myocarditis and possibly dying I don't
think this was a thing all over the all
over the place on soccer fields and
South that's what I'm saying but I'm
saying five years if they're they're
trying to make it out this has none of
the vaccines I don't think and it's just
we're just noticing it now I don't think
there would have been enough to notice
here's my here's my question why why is
the immediate assumption it's vaccines
and not that it was covered we so we
know that myocarditis covet does cause
myocarditis okay uh and we know that
that's true it was the alpha the alpha
stream was brutal was super brutal and
then over time as it started to mutate
it became less and less serious the very
strange Omicron whatever so the first
trains were were nuts so you know all
these we see these documentaries like um
what was that one where the they're
pulling the clots out of the body oh
yeah but but suddenly I died suddenly I
saw that and I said
could kovid be doing this and the weird
thing to me about it is you've got this
conspiracy theory and I'm not saying
that to be disparaging to people who
don't trust big Pharma the idea being
that there is these vaccines may be
causing blood clots they call it the
clotch on stuff like that and I'm like
here's a conspiracy theory covid was
manufactured through gain of function
research doc fauci funded it it was made
in the lab it leaked and is causing
extreme reactions that we're seeing
which results in blood clots and
myocarditis true what about that
conspiracy theory right right I mean
that could accept that one that's that's
what I'm saying I mean I I think also to
your point it's kind of telling that
you're now in a position to make that
question on on air and not have be shut
down completely and totally now there's
two possibilities one people push back
enough and they're like okay or that
there's enough data that what you're
just asking about can no longer just be
pretended to be just tin foil had
nonsense no it's proven it's fact this
one thing that a lot of a lot of the
Liberals brought up encounter to you
know vaccine starts trending when
bronnie James has this news breaks and a
bunch of Liberals are like hey covid
causes myocarditis and it does and it
did like well before the vaccines we
were seeing it I don't know if there's
enough news I always feel like it would
cause it in young people and young
athletes if it might cause it in someone
who's older and weaker already but like
if the whole thing with covet is it's
not targeting young people and in fact
children don't know that though well we
know that in terms of the death rates
and things like that well but death
rate's not the same as as transmission I
could see like I read a study that said
that a lot of uh infants uh you know
that are born dead I can't remember the
word for it stillborn stillborn
they have heart issues in you know from
money yeah so we don't know if that's
that the mother had covet or that she I
was talking about it either yeah I had
count dankula in my show and he was
talking about the rates of stillbirth uh
miscarriage in Scotland was like through
the roof yeah that could be that could
be covered yeah I'm just saying but the
thing is it's not nothing right so the
whole point is that absolutely the
argument is this isn't really happening
or just noticing it it just because you
can't think of the cause doesn't mean
the consequence is not occurring but it
should be open to it exactly you know
discussing and like using scientific
method rather than getting in big fist
fights over it's this or that we should
be open to finding out what the hell is
and I don't think it's a partisan issue
like people are dying it's not I mean
this is nothing to do with Republicans
but they make everything into a partisan
fight Democrat Governors put coveted
patients in nursing homes and killed
elderly people they were born they
killed the old people definitely they
aquoma was warned explicitly right the
Javit Center and the come Comfort were
available for housing sick people and he
was like I put them in the nursing homes
and they said if you do that elderly
people will contract covert they will
die he did it anyway and then you had
someone to that he must have done a
calculated risk like if we don't do it
this many people could die if we do that
Center yeah it wasn't even at capacity
it was it was they converted into a
hospital I I said you know that they
that I've heard this I don't know that
it's back but I've seen it reported
aspect that hospitals did get a payoff
for every death yes yes that's true
he was 26. here's what I want to say
about you know uh we have we have this
debate over like DeSantis and Trump and
this conversation comes up and people
often point to you know Trump was buddy
buddy with fauci and Trump did Operation
warp speed and I I just want to say you
know look I like experimental medicine a
lot Trump was in favor of right to try
right it's a good thing government
mandates are a bad thing right
corporations mandating people getting
medication and the government through
circuitous methods or direct methods
forcing it is the problem yeah Trump
funding whatever I'm like if I don't if
I'm not forced or anything I I don't
really care right I mean fine whatever I
don't like the big Pharmaceuticals
multi-massive multinational corporations
but I recently just went to Tijuana and
got experimental medication to treat my
my damaged tip and it helped me out
greatly but I chose it so yeah I don't
like the you know my view is not to rag
on Trump because he funded experiments
it's to rag on the politicians and the
the executives who are forcing people to
get medicated is that just me or does it
seem like people criticize Trump for not
being a Libertarian even though they're
not Libertarians like to think that
Trump wouldn't want the government to do
something would would be really kind of
ridiculous in my opinion because Donald
Trump's not a small government kind of
guy he was never that kind of dude he he
knew how to work the government in New
York to to you know be able to get at
least some buildings built and stuff so
I the idea that Donald the idea that
Donald Trump needs to be held
accountable in the way that you would
hold a Libertarian accountable seems uh
seems off to me I think they're more
trying to hold him accountable for
trusting people that he should have
known are nefarious Fair that's the
issue I think for Trump supporters well
who else was he getting attracted it's
not like that was anybody decent to
choose from hello hello hello
yeah yeah he brought on Bolton I think
that was because uh one of his donors
wanted him to bring on John Bolton and
then Bolton stabs in the back yeah Trump
brought on so many dumb people like Rex
Tillerson was the dumbest guy he I mean
pouch is the most wrong guy look
remember with AIDS in fact he remembered
back then well I I don't remember it but
I've read a lot about it I've been going
I do and my brother's gay you know and I
remember when AIDS was the big thing and
thought you was the problem then too
yeah I just finished watching this uh uh
superb uh miniseries from back in the
day called angels in America about the
other crisis oh yeah and I I think this
I might write even write a book about at
some point because I think people have
forgotten how dark it was and it was a
joke because it was happening to them
and like hahaha and it was it's really
if you look back it was extremely
disturbing how this population was
treated and like I just also supported I
heard conspiracy theory about the MMR
vaccine 1980 they established and they
distribute a mass distribution of the
MMR vaccine some new vaccine and it was
this is the conspiracy theories that it
was tainted with HIV right I heard that
a lot of people got it but most people
were able to fight it off it was the
people doing poppers and partying until
5am that got really sick
and it's like no it's because their
bodies are weakened we don't we don't
need that conspiracy because we know
that Bayer had tainted uh hemophilia
medication yeah that's that's
historically yeah fact well have you
heard of Celia Farber she's a great
journalist and she went back in the 90s
when I when I was on my show she brought
me evidence she's a prize-winning
journalist and she she had traced it
back to the salt vaccine the place in
Africa where they tested on those
children the sulk and the Sabe and polio
vaccine is the same place AIDS
originated you know this is a uh it's
like a it's like a dangerous YouTube
subject either way because I don't I
don't know I I
I'm not inclined to immediately say that
vaccines caused whatever so many
conspiracy theories no but I'm just
saying like experimenting on a captive
population is always bad yeah yeah you
know you can't you can't do that but
like oh so I just watched the Bohemian
Rhapsody the movie
Queen such an amazing Band Bohemian
Rhapsody is it the greatest song of all
time yeah perhaps absolutely and uh so
I'm watching we built this city it's the
greatest that's a good song no he was
the greatest singer ever you think so
he's your favorite yeah I just I queen
is so good it you know and especially
after watching that movie I'm listening
to all their songs again after all this
time and I'm like eclectic yes that's a
good thing about them yeah
operatic just so amazing and
groundbreaking this may be a little
crass but I Love Don't Stop Me Now but
every time I I listen to that I'm like
you know one second thought someone
should have stopped that guy oh God Tim
that's a Michael malice joke what I'm
not saying to be mean I'm not saying it
as a joke I literally people should have
been like someone should have at least
moderated him but this is gonna stop him
but yeah that wasn't the time
but but it's it's you're you know
Michael's over here he's very laughing
he likes it but I'm not saying it's a
joke I'm saying it this guy was doing
drugs he was partying non-stop all the
time that destroys his immune system he
contracts HIV and I'm just like
that that's such a brutal thing but you
know my point is when it comes to these
conspiracy theories about what really
happened I'm like these stories are all
people who as like Ian pointed out are
doing a bunch of drugs all the time rock
and roll they're having tons of sex all
the time
we have actually a control group for
this because we have someone here who
had that level of Fame so when you were
like at the top of your power how would
someone have put you in check if they
wanted to because like when you're like
Freddie Mercury level I feel like no one
can tell you anything no you're damn
right yeah if they try you're out of
there right they're not gonna tell me I
made this money this is my money and
I'll deal with it as I choose yeah right
now it is
people like they end up dead that is the
truth no but but my point is not that
you could have stopped Freddie Mercury
my point is that no I hear you but I'm
just saying it's interesting we can
actually talk to someone that level of
faith I I wouldn't let nobody stop no
but right right but my point is not that
he would have been stopped his my point
is where how does this disease come
about because these people can't be
stopped right these celebrities Ultra
rock stars promiscuous they don't want
to stop it's a big suicidal trip it's
like hey you've you've reached the peak
and you've done everything there is to
do you don't want to downslide now
you're not going back you're going out
yeah thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time